hello everyone and welcome to the last
game we'll be showing from the charity
cup finals it's young
versus magnus carlsen and this is the
second game of the playoffs so for those
of you who aren't following what's been
happening magnus won the first match
then duda retaliated in in the second
match which was incredible because
magnus won the first game of the second
match uh and then duda won two games in
a row so that was uh
really really awesome uh and then he
forced tie breaks and the first game of
the tie breaks magnus one with the white
pieces so this is the second game of the
thai breaks and the duda now needs a win
to push the competition even further
into the tiebreaks and hopefully to
reach armageddon so this is now blitz
and the variations get much much
sharper so you guys will enjoy this one
but just a quick uh announcement or
rather not an announcement um uh sort of
information sharing for you guys uh
dinglin has started playing a classical
tournament so he is on his way to
getting all the games that he needs to
qualify for the candidates tournament he
already won the first two games uh today
he's playing the third one so we'll see
uh he's already 28.03 something in
ratings uh so he might
even overtake ferruja as the number two
player in the world
before reaching the candidates uh so
that being said let's check out what
happened here uh it's a very very short
game so do that with the white pieces
opens with e4 and magnus goes for c6 he
goes for the karo khan defense we have d
for d5 and now duda plays f3 this is the
so-called fantasy variation of the karo
khan we have e6 and now knight to c3 we
have knight to f6 e5 and grabbing more
space in the center that's a pretty
standard idea knight after d7 now
preparing c5 knight c to e2 making room
for the pawn to be pushed to c3 after
black plays c5 and this is exactly what
happened c5 c3
and knight to c6 uh we have f4
strengthening the uh the center here and
now uh there are a couple of moves that
are very popular in this position like
a5 or we could uh strike against the
whites a very strong center with f6 but
magnus first goes bishop to e7 he wants
the castle and then he's going to try
and
break the strong center so here at
knight f3 uh we have castles and now h4
uh duda is um is in a must-win situation
and he will play this game uh well
everything to win uh magnus plays f6 a
standard idea here but this also means
that he has weakened the e6 pawn and now
it might not seem like a pretty big deal
but for the moment the the e6 pawn is
not defended and duda finds a very
interesting way of how to exploit this
with a3
a5 by magnus and now knight the g3 the
knight again will be very useful here we
are hoping to get our bishop to d3 the
queen might come to h5 the the knight
will also have have something to do here
but magnus just plays queen to b6 he
says there is nothing to worry about on
the king's side luda says all right
bishop to d3 and now c captures on d4
so what can do the play here well there
is only one thing he can do and that is
to go for the win and that is knight the
g5 now he's threatening to pick up the
h7 pawn he also opened up this diagonal
for the queen to come to h5 it's a very
tricky position magnus is very very
close to winning the entire thing but he
has to play the absolute correct move
here so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the move that will well uh
it's not a winning move for black but
it's it's a move that
will make it very very hard for white to
to continue playing the game so uh have
at it what would you play here with
black
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not capturing the
knight and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show the move is of
course h6 but i imagine you guys
probably thought okay we're not
capturing the knight you were
well considering maybe f5 and h6
but we're going to show what happens on
each of these because if knight is
captured then after bishop captures an
h7 you just resign if king f7 queen h5
ends the game and if you capture the the
bishop king h8 also just queen h5 so
after king captures an h7 we just open
up the h file for the rook and after we
move the king g6 and that's it all of
these squares are now covered queen h5
queen to h7 will be checkmate so what
happens after f5 it's also an
interesting idea the problem is uh white
will get
in well sort of an equal position after
knight captures on e6 we're going to
play knight c captures on e5 open up and
attack towards the knight here knight
captures on f8 we're going to play
knight captures on d3 with check queen
captures king captures and now after c
captures on d4 let's say knight f6 and
it's a well uh sort of an equalish
position black a white might castle here
and the game continues however after the
move magnus played h6 uh do this
position is not
not a fun one to play so he goes for the
e6 pawn uh we said that it might seem
like a hard target to acquire but uh
duda
does it anyway knight captures an e6 and
now knight d captures on e5 so grabbing
the e5 pawn and opening up the attack
towards the knight duda grabs the rook
on f8 and now knight captures on d3 with
check we have queen captures on d3 and
the bishop captures nf8 and this is now
the scary position that dududa finds
himself in there is only one move that
allows him to keep playing the game with
having just a slightly worse position
and that is rook to b1 uh the reason for
this will be revealed shortly but the
duda played bishop to d2
and now the position is uh winning for
magnus and there are a couple of ways
that you could play this magnus goes for
the absolute most precise one of course
you don't want to capture on b2 then
duda just castles and then he gets what
he wants but after bishop to g4 now uh
it's not so easy now you're not castling
queen side you're definitely not
castling king side if you castle king
said just captures here opens up a
discovery towards the white king and if
bishop e3 attacking the queen blocking
check just d4
and bishop f2 captures on b2 you have a
passport on b2 this is game over so
after bishop g4 duda tries queen to g6
now attacking the bishop here but now
queen captures on b2 now attacking the
rook here so you have to react to this
rook to b1 now you know why the rook
belonged on b1 all along and now rook to
e8 with check it's pretty much the only
move that wins um but it's it's an easy
one to spot so magnus just plays that
rook at the e8 with check king to f1 and
now queen captures on d2 we have queen
captures an e8 uh giving up the rook as
well uh also after this rook to e8 check
if you just go for queen captures uh
then you no longer guard the rook if
anyone missed that for some reason uh so
uh just a king to f1 we have queen
captures on d2 now queen captures on e8
but not just queen captures an f4 with
check king to g1 we have queen captures
and g3 everything completely falls apart
duda plays rook captures on b7 but now
after knight to e5 there is absolutely
nothing more for white to do here uh and
uh of course you can't even deliver a
single check so it was in this position
on move uh
24 or rather maybe it's 25 no at animal
24 uh that young shisht of duda resigned
the game and a brilliant brilliant
victory for magnus carlsen uh so uh you
could continue with something like rook
to b1 but uh like the captures on c3 and
that's i mean
there's no playing this and if you try
something like rook here uh it's
actually a mating three just queen to e1
with check king will move knight f3
check and after this is captured we're
gonna play queen to f2 with checkmate
bishop covers the h3 square and that's
it so of course after 95 dude are
resigned and magnus takes yet another
victory uh in this meltweather champions
chester or rather charity cup as this
one was renamed into it
uh so yeah really really impressive
stuff magnus said in an interview after
the game that he completely collapsed on
the second day but that he was uh still
able to prevail uh and well for duda
this was definitely a great great
experience as he's like i said one of
the members of the 2022 candidates
tournament and if he wins he will be
challenging magnus carlsen for the world
title if magnus carlsen will even defend
his title but here he got a little taste
of what it uh what it would be like of
course it would be a completely
different story it would be much much
harder it would be
much more preparation would go into that
but here you you had uh eight rapid
games against the world champion and
also two blitz games so i was uh well a
definitely
a good experience for duda and well he
almost uh he almost bonds back and won
the entire thing winning day two after
losing the first game was incredible
feat in itself uh but then in blitz
magnus was just uh well
it was just his day
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it we are now shifting to
the coverage of the
of the uh berlin uh video grand prix and
if dink plays a nice game or two we're
gonna cover that as well so if you have
any of your own favorite games uh from
uh these events do share in the comments
using hashtag suggestion i will go over
it and of course uh show them i already
have a few that you guys suggested yeah
that's the game ended this short
coverage of the charity cup hope you
guys enjoyed this i would like to thank
a symbolic donation from a subscriber
david kimura make me some is open c
smokey doula and tyler richko for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
other events that are currently taking
place in the world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent start of your week